face aux caméras à l'armée russe vente
les qualités et la richesse de ses
équipements au nouveau conscrit à
travers ces vidéos fournies par la
télévision des tarus Moscou veut aussi
montrer la bonne préparation des soldats
avant d'être envoyé au front pourtant
depuis la mobilisation partielle les
magasins d'équipements militaires russes
comme celui-ci sont pris d'assaut les
réservistes viennent y acheter ce que le
gouvernement ne leur fournit pas
les gens achètent des lampes torches il
n'y a pas assez de sacs de couchage ni
de matelas avant il y en avait beaucoup
mais maintenant il n'y a plus rien nulle
part
a publié des enregistrements d'appels
téléphoniques de soldats russes à leurs
proches de rares témoignages du moral
des troupes au fond et de ce qu'ils ont
vécu en Ukraine à mon retour je
démissionne j'emmerde l'armée Poutine
les fous il veut prendre Kiev mais on y
arrivera pas
les quoique autour de la mobilisation
contribuent aussi à ternir l'image de la
guerre voulu par Poutine auprès des
Russes des pères de famille nombreuses
ou encore des malades chroniques ont été
enrôlées pour la première fois Vladimir
Poutine a reconnu des erreurs et après
il faut traiter chaque cas
individuellement ici nous avons commis
cette erreur je le répète il faut la
corriger et ramener à la maison ceux qui
ont été incorporés sans que les
exigences de la mobilisation étaient
prises en compte l'annonce de la
mobilisation partielle a entraîné de
nombreuses manifestations en Russie plus
de 2400 personnes ont été arrêtées des
milliers d'autres ont décidé de fuir le
pays